Why should you become a Muslim? Is it
because Islam is full of wisdom? Is it
because Islam teaches moral precepts
that you don't find anywhere else? Is it
because Islam will give you
enlightenment into things you had not
otherwise known? Is it because Islam is
full of love and compassion for all
human beings? Let's look at why the
Quran says you should become a Muslim.
They will suffer an awful doom.
They will suffer a painful doom because
they lie. For unbelievers, there is a
shameful doom. Each of them would like
to be allowed to live a thousand years,
and to live would by no means remove him
from the doom. For unbelievers, there is
a painful doom. For them there is
disgrace in this world and for them in
the hereafter is an awful doom.
The doom will not be lightened for them
nor will they be reprieved.
If only those who do evil had known when
they see doom that power belongs wholly
to Allah and that Allah is severe in
punishment.
When those who were followed disown
those who followed and they see doom and
all their plans collapse with them, a
painful doom will be theirs. He who
transgresses after this will have a
painful doom. Indeed, those who
disbelieve in the signs of Allah, theirs
will be a heavy doom. Indeed, those who
disbelieve the signs of Allah and kill
the prophets wrongfully and kill those
of mankind who enjoin equity, promise
them a painful doom. Theirs will be a
painful doom. Their doom will not be
lightened, nor will they be reprieved.
Theirs will be a painful doom, and they
will have no helpers. For such people,
there is an awful doom. It is Allah's
will to assign them no share in the
hereafter and theirs will be an awful
doom.
Those who buy disbelief at the price of
faith do not harm Allah at all but
theirs will be a painful doom
and theirs will be a shameful doom.
Do not think that those who rejoice in
what they have given and love to be
praised for what they have not done. do
not think that they are in safety from
the doom, a painful doom is theirs.
And whoever disobys Allah and his
messenger and transgresses his limits,
he will make him enter fire that where
he will dwell forever, his will be a
shameful doom. For such people, we have
prepared a painful doom. For
unbelievers, we prepare a shameful doom.
Allah is angry with him and he has
cursed him and prepared for him an awful
doom. Bring to the hypocrites the news
that for them there is a painful doom.
Such people are actually unbelievers and
for unbelievers we have prepared a
shameful doom.
And for their taking userie when they
were forbidden to take it, and of their
devouring people's wealth by false by
means of false pretenses, we have
prepared for those among them who
disbelieve a painful doom.
Then for those who believed and did good
works, to them he will pay their wages
in full, giving them more from his
bounty. And as for those who were
disdainful and proud, then he will
punish with a painful doom. Such will be
their degradation in this world and in
the hereafter theirs will be an awful
doom. As for those who disbelieve
indeed, if all that is on earth were
theirs, and the same amount again with
it, to ransom them from doom on the day
of resurrection, it would not be
accepted from them. Theirs will be a
painful doom. Theirs will be a lasting
doom. Theirs will be disgrace in this
world and in the hereafter an awful
doom. If they do not stop saying this, a
painful doom will fall on those who
among them who disbelieve. Surely what
they themselves send on before them is
harmful for them. Allah will be angry
with them and in the doom they will
remain. Whoever transgresses after this,
for him there is a painful doom. For
them is drink of boiling water and a
painful doom because they disbelieved.
We award an evil doom to those who turn
away from our signs because of their
aversion. And the first of them says to
the last of them, "You are not a bit
better than we were. So taste the doom
for what you used to earn." And when
they and when a community among them
said, "Why do you preach to a people
whom Allah is about to destroy or punish
with an awful doom?" And when they said,
"Oh Allah, if this is indeed the truth
from you, then rain down stones on us or
bring us some painful doom." And their
prayer at the house is nothing but
whistling and handclapping. Therefore,
taste of the doom because you
disbelieve.
If it had not been for a decree of Allah
which went before, an awful doom would
have come upon you because of what you
took. Give news of a painful doom to
those who disbelieve.
They who hoard up gold and silver and do
not spend it in the way of Allah. Give
news to them of a painful doom. If you
do not go forth, he will afflict you
with a painful doom and will choose a
people other than you instead of you.
say, "Are you waiting for anything to
happen to us except one of two good
things while we await for you that Allah
will afflict you with a doom from him or
at our hands?" Those who annoy the
messenger of Allah, for them there is a
painful doom. If they repent, it will be
better for them. And if they turn away,
Allah will afflict them with a painful
doom in this world and the hereafter.
and they have no protecting friend nor
helper in the earth. Theirs will be a
painful doom. A painful doom will fall
upon those among them who disbelieve. We
know them and we will punish them twice.
Then they will be relegated to a painful
doom. Indeed, he produces creation then
reproduces it so that he may reward
those who believe and do good works with
justice. While as for those who
disbelieve, theirs will be a boiling
drink and painful doom because they
disbelieved.
Say, have you thought when the doom
comes to you as a raid by night or in
the day what there is of it that the
guilty ones want to hasten?
And if each soul that does wrong had
everything that is on earth, it would
seek to ransom itself with it, and they
will feel remorse within them when they
see the doom. Then we make them taste a
dreadful doom because they used to
disbelieve.
Our Lord, destroy their riches and
harden their hearts so that they do not
believe until they see the painful doom.
Even though every sign comes to them
until they see the painful doom. And if
we delay the doom for them until a
reckoned time, they will surely say,
"What holds it back?" And you will know
to whom a punishment comes that will
confound him, and upon whom a lasting
doom will fall. A painful doom from us
will overtake them. And when our
commandment came to pass, we saved Hood
and those who believed with him by a
mercy from us. and we saved them from a
harsh doom. Oh Abraham, forsake this.
Indeed, your Lord's commandment has gone
forth, and indeed there comes to them a
doom that cannot be repelled. You will
soon know on whom there comes a doom
that will humiliate him, and who it is
that lies. She said, "What will be his
reward? who wishes evil upon your people
except prison or a painful doom.
When Allah dooms, there is no one who
can postpone his doom. And he is swift
at reckoning. Allah to whom belongs
whatever is in the heavens and whatever
is in the earth. And woe to the
unbelievers from an awful doom
which he sips but can hardly swallow.
and death comes to him from every side
while he still cannot die. And before
him is a harsh dune.
Then those who were despised say to
those who were scornful, we we merely
followed you. Can you then avert from us
any part of Allah's doom? Indeed, for
wrongdoers is a painful doom and warn
mankind of a day when the doom will come
upon them, and that my doom is the
painful doom.
those before them plotted. So Allah
struck at the foundations of their
building and then the roof fell down
upon them from above them and doom came
on them.
Are those who plan evil deeds then
secure that Allah will not cause the
earth to swallow them or that doom will
not come upon them from what they do not
know.
Theirs will be a painful doom. And when
those who did wrong see the doom, it
will not be made light for them, nor
will they be reprieved. For those who
disbelieve and bar people from the way
of Allah, we add doom to doom because
they spread corruption. Yours would be
an awful doom. Indeed, those who
disbelieve the signs of Allah, Allah
does not guide them, and theirs will be
a painful doom.
Theirs will be an awful doom, a brief
enjoyment, and theirs is a painful doom.
And that those who do not believe in the
hereafter, for them we have prepared a
painful doom.
Those to whom they call seek the way of
approach to their Lord, which among them
will be the nearest. They hope for his
mercy, and they fear his doom.
Then they will call upon them, but they
will not hear their prayer. And we will
set a gulf of doom between them. And
nothing hinders mankind from believing
when the guidance comes to them, and
from asking forgiveness of their Lord,
unless that the judgment of the men of
old should come upon them, or they
should be confronted with the doom.
If he rebuked them for what they earn,
he would hasten on the doom for them.
But theirs is an appointed term from
which they will find no escape. Indeed,
it has been revealed to us that the doom
will be for him who denies and turns
away.
There are many for whom the doom is
justly deserved. Indeed, those who
disbelieve and bar people from the way
of Allah and from the sacred mosque
which we have appointed for mankind
together, the dweller in it and the
nomad, whoever seeks wrongful partiality
in it, him we will cause to taste a
painful doom. And they will ask you to
hasten on the doom. And Allah does not
fail to keep his promise.
While those who disbelieved and denied
our signs, for them will be a shameful
doom. To every man among them, what he
has earned of the sin. And as for him
among them who had the greater share in
it, his will be an awful doom. If it had
not been for the favor of Allah and his
mercy to you in the world and the
hereafter, an awful doom would have
overtaken you for what you had whispered
about. Theirs will be an awful doom. We
have prepared a painful doom for
evildoers. They will know when they see
the doom who is more astray from the
road. The doom will be doubled for him
on the day of resurrection, and he will
remain in it disdained forever. They
will not believe in it until they see
the painful doom. Would they hasten on
our doom? And it will be said, "Call
upon your partners, and they will call
out to them, and they will give no
answer to them, and they will see the
doom." For such people, there is a
painful doom.
They ask you to hasten on the doom, and
if a term had not been appointed, the
doom would surely have come upon them.
They ask you to hasten on the doom, when
indeed gehenna will indeed encompass the
unbelievers.
on the day when the doom will overwhelm
them from above them and from under
their feet. And he will say, "Taste what
you used to do." But as for those who
disbelieved and denied our revelations
and denied the meeting of the hereafter,
such people will be brought to doom.
For such people there is a shameful
doom. So give him news of a painful
doom. We give them comfort for a while
and then we drive them to a heavy doom.
And he has prepared a painful doom for
the unfaithful. And they are filled with
remorse when they behold the doom. And
as for those who strive against our
signs, challenging they will be brought
to the doom. He is nothing but a warner
to you in the face of a terrible doom.
Those who disbelieve, theirs will be an
awful doom.
To him good words ascend, and he exalts
the pious deed. But those who plot
iniquities, theirs will be an awful
doom. Then indeed, this day they are
sharers in the doom. Indeed, truly you
taste the painful doom. No, but they are
in doubt about my reminder. No, but they
have not yet tasted my doom.
Each denied the messengers. Therefore,
my doom was justified. Indeed, those who
stray from the way of Allah have an
awful doom. Is he on whom the word of
doom is fulfilled? Can you rescue him
who is in the fire? Is he then one who
will strike his face against the awful
doom upon the day of resurrection? Those
before them denied, and so the doom came
upon them from where they did not know
who it is to whom a doom comes that will
humiliate him, and on whom there falls
everlasting doom. And although those who
do wrong possess all that is in the
earth, and with it as much again, they
indeed will seek to ransom themselves
with it from the awful doom on the day
of resurrection. And there will appear
to them from the Lord something they had
not expected. Turn to your Lord in
repentance and submit to him before the
doom comes to you when you cannot be
helped.
And follow the better of what is
revealed to you from your Lord before
the doom comes on you suddenly when you
do not know or says when it sees the
doom. If only I had a second chance so
that I might be among the righteous. So
Allah warded off from him the evils
which they plotted while a dreadful doom
encompassed Pharaoh's people.
The fire they are exposed to it morning
and evening. And on the day when the
hour comes cause Pharaoh's people to
enter the most awful doom.
Then when they saw our doom, they said,
"We believe in Allah alone and reject
what we used to associate."
But their faith could not help them when
they saw our doom. But indeed, we will
cause those who disbelieved to taste an
awful doom. And indeed, we will repay
them with the worst of what they used to
do. Wrath is upon them, and theirs will
be an awful doom. Indeed, for wrongdoers
is a painful doom. And as for
unbelievers, theirs will be an awful
doom. For such people, there is a
painful doom. And you will see the
evildoers when they see the doom. They
say, "Is there any way of return?" And
it does not profit you this day because
you did wrong that you will be sharers
in the doom. Give him news of a painful
doom. For such people there is a
shameful doom. Theirs will be an awful
doom. Oh our people, respond to Allah's
summoner and believe in him. He will
forgive you some of your sins and guard
you from a painful doom. Then taste the
doom for what you disbelieved. He will
punish you with a painful doom. He will
punish him with a painful doom. You too
throw him to the dreadful doom. And we
left behind in it a sign for those who
fear a painful doom. Then there will
separate them a wall in which there is a
gate, the inner side of which contains
mercy, while the outer side of it is
toward the doom. For unbelievers is a
painful doom. For unbelievers is a
shameful doom. Allah has prepared for
them a dreadful doom. Theirs will be a
shameful doom. Oh you who believe, shall
I show you a transaction that will save
you from a painful doom? Hasn't story
reached you of those who disbelieved of
old and so tasted the evil consequences
of their conduct and theirs will be a
painful doom. Who will protect the
unbelievers from a painful doom? A
questioner questioned concerning the
doom about to fall upon the unbelievers
and those who are fearful of their
Lord's doom. Indeed, we sent Noah to his
people. Warn your people before the
painful doom comes to them. And food
that chokes and a painful doom on him I
will impose a fearful doom. He makes
those whom he wills to enter his mercy.
And for evildoers had prepared a painful
doom. Indeed, we warn you of a doom at
hand. So give them tidings of a painful
doom.
[Music]
And then there's John 3:16 which says,
"For God so loved the world that he gave
his only begotten son that whoever
believes in him should not perish but
have everlasting Right.